hey youtubers is charlie is this gonna
be my flash episode 6 video
we get an official name for the flash
turns out he wasn't a huge fan
the red streak which i think is kinda
funny made a numeric human
and we get details for the last couple
episodes for the first half of the
season
the producers made some comments about
the second half to the season in terms
that
new a row crossovers saw mention that
the into the video
in has some updates on Katie Cassidy is
Black Canary careful first pushing the
episode if you not cut up but starting
with top five moments
number five barry in iris it's not so
much period iris
as it is iris in the Flash it only have
a Superman Lois Lane thing going on
probably not gonna go quite as well as
it did in the Superman comics
one other things I really like about the
flash is that you know uses retreading
a lot of familiar comic book round but
is trying to do it in a new and
interesting way
changing characters names changing
relationships up that's the biggest
chance it it has
not going too far from the comics but i
doing in the way that
everyone totally understand up front pay
close attention to the love triangle is
developing between
Eddie iris in Barrie right now though or
to flash the flesh is kinda like a
second character and irises mind
the any character is coming into frame
so the more and more and as he develops
a relationship with barry
it can get really interesting between
the three of them number four
barry in eighty team up it's like their
flash Bros in this episode
it is a totally nice guy for all we know
is very mysterious just because the
story hasn't focused on him a lot
and we mostly seen him through the veil
up his relationship with Iris
but now he and Perry have some common
ground they were both bullied as
children
any seems like he's conquered his
demands a little bit more than Barry has
acuna dealing with quite as many issues
so I would call him like the big brother
in this situation
in this relationship I fully expected to
get some more scenes like this before
the mid-season finale
were episode 9 it is quote became really
important to medically to the episode I
mean it can it synced up with the
supersonic punch
the idea of letting your opponent wear
himself out in the past the flashes
defeated the reverse plaster
professors in whichever version to the
rivers flashy was fighting just by
dodging punches
it's like is by with girder like he just
keeps taking swings Adam
barry just keeps dodging saving energy
fighting smarter
not fighting stronger
that's gonna be really important when
the Man in the Yellow Sea shows up but
sexy the title the personae now talk
about that a little bit
flash Bros also gave us our first visit
to Keystone city
it's a big place in the comic books and
it's going to be placed on the show
eventually
it's mostly known as the home at the
Wally West flash regulating the
producers confirm they would do him at
some point
favor part the berry Eddie scenes wear
them talking about boys like bonding
over boys bullies
are really important because the reverse
last is a bully to the flash
number three Joe verses here some wells
I got so excited when Joe walked into
Star laps and said
I need help finding perry's mother's
killer there's that look
on here some wall space priceless
regardless at how he's connected to the
flash
he knows all about that because he can
either see through time or is a time
traveler
regardless he knows all about it he
knows who really killed her
they did confirm here small showed up
right after Berry's mother was murdered
so we can add that to the theory board
test Morgan was the name of the woman
that he mentioned that was his wife
important thing about that is is that
she could also be connected to perry's
mother's murder
they're both scientists working on the
same type of technology that led to the
particle accelerator
the way he explained it made it sound
like he been around for a long time
but he didn't travel back in time right
to the time of the murder
so if he is the murder there's a much
more complicated explanation
he explained that she died in a car
accident which in comic books can
sometimes be code for something really
sinister happening
a run in with the supervillain so it
appears in Wells is not the reverse
flasher wanna the river splashes
it's possible that the person to visit a
joke the end of the episode
also visited here some wells and killed
his wife it would make sense
appears in Wells is critical to the
development of the flash even if he is
responsible for the Speed Force
he's the person that helping barry
figure out his powers their whole
conversation
really raise more questions than it
answered so here's a quick rundown
the best theories that i've seen about
who cares and Wells is right now
the top two are one a virgin at the
river slash the professor zoom
reverse flash to aversion to barry allen
from the future stuck
in the past and then three 12 the ropes
from the future
we have data for that now he could be a
completely new person
not from the comics who just gets tied
up in the creation the flag
ash number two Bay reverses girder
supersonic punch for the win
i knows little confusing when they were
fighting but yes he was blind through
mid air so
at some point he jumped if you're not
familiar with girder from the comics his
name's
Anthony Woodward the only thing that's
different the comics is it the fact that
he got dumped in
was for scrap metal from a star labs
experiment
just our lives is still responsible for
his creation is that on the show with
the particle accelerator explosion
also in the comments he didn't grow up
with the flashlight getting to the same
school
but he was still a giant douchebag this
episode for the flash was all about
learning to fight bill instead are
stronger than he is
that's my girder look like a big muscle
man like he was
too big for barry to walk up and punch
so as much as it was buried verses
girder
it was barry purses physics this be
forced to listen to get kinda tie me why
me
with the laws of physics I tried to poke
too many holes in that kinda stuff just
because
it'll make your head spin but I do like
the way the shows explaining things if
you like it satisfactory
and my number one moment of course the
reverse last visits Joe
and I just been a sec talking about here
some wells done that's changed
but he still all the research the Joe
had collected on the Man in the Yellow
sued
that's still what they're calling on the
show but really is the reverse flash
what we find out who that actually is
the person in this suit
know which version other rivers flashed
a column its religious zoom and
professors in that have worn the yellow
suit though
I will go on record as saying I totally
do not care who the reverse light ends
up being
as long as the explanation is
interesting I think it's gonna be
amazing
like I said the title episode 9 is
called the man in the yellow suit
have no idea what's going to be
happening in that episode we can
cm they could explain 'em person wells
could say something about him
I think it'll just be a tease if you
member area season 2
the Justice League at the end of that
this 09 we didn't see him full-on
Deathstroke until the second half to the
season let me know that what was your
favorite moment the episode and he's my
big question for you guys
who do you think the man in the lawsuit
is now based on what we saw in this
episode
so there were a couple more ease rates
be dropped in the episode
first was the man who was on buyer who
apparently doesn't burn
that could either be firestorm or could
be heat wave both those are characters
that we won't see to the second half of
the season
they will appear in the same episode
like firestorm and heat wave are going
to be in the same episode
the news here's an well shout out to a
man made of steel
Amanda Steele as in Superman if he knows
the future he knows all about the
Justice League
and Clark Kent and others have a
question about whether or not he's alive
in this continuity
yes superman Texas in the television
universe we just haven't seen him yet
then I risk is bare his official name
the flash which will go down in history
as a
pretty big deal I'm including this might
use race just because in the episode it
didn't feel like as big a payoff but it
was kinda given offhandedly like
he when we do the flash maybe that'll
work and here when he went to Keystone
city you can see the site it says
garrett's work as NJ garrick the
original Golden Age flash
overall a good episode a-minus just for
the way appeared characters of like I
love
the berry any pairing I love Joe and
doctor wells
I really wanna see more of that like
really unusual pairings characters that
you don't normally see together
among other things that the class is
done I mean they're really gung-ho with
the way they do super villain
superpowers
if you like they're amazing at
developing characters that's mostly due
to the writers
in the actors nailing it I was in a
giant fan at the actor the plate girder
but he was playing a douche bag so that
was me mostly heating douchebags
so he did his job very effectively it
was our job to hate him
just in terms a comic book shows in
general if you like Aaron the flash at
the best creative teams
me they have Geoff Johns creative lead
at DC Comics working on one of the shows
directly
it says a lot when the person who
informs the creative direction
up olive DC Comics is working on your
show
that is good you ninety at the level of
importance to their training with so
there's three episodes left in the
season here some details on what's going
on with that
next week's episode features for root AK
black out
antioch man he's the clocking from a row
you consider it like a subtle prison
break up said to
although many other roads are in it the
week after that will be the big
crossover with a row
member that's two parts part 1 will be
on the flash that's called last person 0
part 2 will be on a row and they'll be
called The Brave and the bold in and the
midseason finale is called the man in
the yellow suit BB the week after that
so they'll be a new flash episode each
week for the next three weeks but no
break
as we get closer to the midseason finale
I'll try to post a couple more bonus
videos about special characters things
that are coming up
so feel free to make requests and be
sure to subscribe to get everything
the cast a barrel was posting some more
pictures have Katie Cassidy inner Black
Canary costume from episodes they were
filming
I think I'll talk about that more during
my air a video tomorrow but I think
they're filming episode 11 or 12 by now
the big thing the you guys should really
get excited about is the idea up another
crossover in the second half of the
season between Aaron the flash
the producer said they had to wait till
after the flash got picked up for a full
season
for the planet but they're just starting
to right now really quick heads up to
you to give me a new beta future to play
with so if you watching this on your
mobile phone or on a tablet
there's an extra link that you can click
on here like that I talk about
the link that I add over here too will
always be the same
but right now you can click here for
last week's episode the flash
in click here to get ready for air this
week thank you so much watching
atop a pipe I'll see guest tomorrow